foreign
[Music]
Once Upon a Time an American moved to
London and he brought with him as pet
tiger and a toothbrush
well you've done it again haven't you
like on a plane
you want to do with that
did you pay for ticket
said the air hostess yes I did the tiger
is very well traveled as a matter of
fact and the longer we have this
conversation the longer it's more likely
he'll do it on the plane the tiger speak
this is a very well traveled is educated
and at Customs they're like this is not
something that's supposed to happen you
can't bring Americans to London okay you
can't bring Americans to London so he
brings him to a cat cafe
but they don't stay because they only
serve tea really okay dude do something
with that
he pointed at one of the kittens and
said this is your fault your Ginger why
are you so Orange
why do they only serve tea cried the
American causing a bit of a Ruckus they
go to the zoo next because that's where
the tiger wants to go they spot a ball a
football all the animals playing in the
dark it's not the soccer he knows
he wants to go home
what were the last two things
this is all you and the Americans said
the big
problem with London is there are no
decent
omelette chefs and nobody's talking
about it
and then the tiger growl
and in the growl the American could
decipher are you a chef
the tiger Cuts up his leg
and then makes a human omelette with
lots of chorizo ham and spices from
India because the tiger is from India
now that we're on the subject of tigers
and kitchens incidentally tigers are
very good chefs you know they have good
pan control not a lot of people know
that one sentence the human rose up from
the plate
said I will not be eaten by anybody
walked off into the night the American
said
I'm going back home thank you very much
everybody
the end the end the end the
[Music]
the end